si l'être avec nous sur rt france alors
que pensez vous des propositions faites
par le gouvernement pour ces épreuves du
baccalauréat et du brevet elles sont
parfaitement cohérente vu la situation
exceptionnelle dans laquelle nous sommes
on pouvait pas faire autrement revanche
il faudra rester très vigilant que ce
bac locale puisque c'est vraiment ce que
c'est pour le coup et se contrôle
continu unique très inéquitable ne se
pérennise pas c'était quand même
l'objectif du gouvernement le condamne
depuis un an et demi maintenant il ne
faut pas que ça soit pérenne
il faut que ce soit exceptionnel on y
veillera est-ce que selon vous le
gouvernement at il bien gérer cette
situation de crise sanitaire vis-à-vis
de l'éducation nationale alors après des
cafouillages au début des menaces
comportement vraiment honteux à l'égard
des enseignants des injonctions
contradictoires
les choses se sont finalement tu as fait
et je crois que monsieur blanc car après
la mesure de ce qui se passait il fait
comme il peut comme nous tous je vais
pas lui jeter la pierre la situation
assez difficile au début c'était hors
digne mais là bon visiblement ça s'est
amélioré dont il fait comme il peut
est ce que le brevet et le bac est passé
cette année ne sont pas des diplômes au
rabais finalement vis-à-vis de cette
situation de crise sanitaire force et
non six ans parti mais enfin bon ça
c'est une évidence
comme dans toute période de crise c'est
ce qui s'était passé en 68 le bac avait
tout le monde avec le bac 68 est un tout
rabais mais c'est pas grave c'est un bac
quand même
il donne accès aux élèves pour ne pas
les pénaliser au même chose que
d'habitude
il leur permettra de poursuivre leur
scolarité ils auront continuer à
amplifier la continuité pédagogique ou
continue alors fait recours tant bien
que mal on fait comme on peut ils font
comme ils peuvent les parents aussi
donc oui ce sera diplôme forcément un
peu au rabais par rapport aux autres
années mais il donnera les mêmes droits
les mêmes possibilités
donc voilà c'est comme ça situation
exceptionnelle mesures exceptionnelles
racontez nous un peu votre quotidien
d'enseignants depuis le début de la
crise comment ça se passe pour vous quel
est votre rapport avec les élèves et les
parents d'élèves
alors le rapport se fait très simplement
par notre
notre rempart notre intranet entre
guillemets notre event et environnement
numérique de travail
j'envoie du travail aux élèves ils
peuvent poser leurs questions les
parents aussi
j'envoie des corrigés je leur envoie des
leçons voilà on peut on peut échanger à
ce sujet la rade pendant les vacances il
ya la possibilité qui est donné aux
enseignants sur la base du volontariat
de faire des cours de rattrapage par
visioconférence pour les élèves en
difficulté pour ne pas complètement les
perdre parce que c'est vrai que c'est
une situation de cours très spécial mais
les choses sont à peu près mise en place
au début c'est pareil ça cafouille et
mais là pour le coup c'était vraiment le
père internet on va dire qu'il est en
cause c'est pas et pas l'éducation
nationale en soit chaque c'est très
difficile que toulon soient connectés en
même temps donc voilà il ya eu des
cafouillages au début l'idée des
matériels et toutes ces mesures elles
sont suivies par les élèves en tout cas
sont respectées par les parents d'élèves
et les élèves en moyenne vous dis
simplement on ne te faire exactement la
même chose finalement dans une scolarité
normale c'est à dire que ce sont
malheureusement les élèves souvent
décrocheurs et en difficulté souvent qui
sont en difficulté ou décrocheurs avec
des parents qui suivent pas toujours
qu'ils ne sont pas leur métier de
parents qui ne font pas leur boulot de
parents qui consiste quand même
s'occuper de la scolarité de son enfant
et le problème c'est que là c'est c'est
encore plus compliqué encore plus
difficile parce que les parents les ont
24 heures sur 24 à la maison ils se
rendent compte qu'ils sont pas si facile
que ça leur enfant ils se rendent compte
que c'est pas facile de faire court que
c'est un vrai métier qui n'ont pas les
compétences pour le faire la plupart du
temps et en tous cas pas dans toutes les
matières et au moins ça va permettre ça
c'est à dire que ça a peut-être remettre
les choses au clair chacun son métier
chacun sa place et peut-être aussi
rappelé aux parents que s'occuper de son
enfant c'est une obligation c'est pas
une option c'est pas une possibilité on
fait pas un enfant pour le faire gérer
par la société une certaine prise de
conscience dernière question rapidement
été l'impact aura le confinement sur la
suite du parcours scolaire des élèves
alors bas le continent va avoir comme
impact qu'ils auront moins bien vu le
programme c'est une évidence on va pas
faire de langue de bois c'est plus
difficile
donc encore une fois on fait comme on
peut je le répète en mai on sait tous
comme on peut on leur faire apprendre le
plus de choses possibles mieux possible
les parents aident comme ils peuvent
les élèves sont à peu près comme ils
peuvent sachant que pour ma part ce sont
des ados donc
les mettre au boulot à distance un peu
plus compliqué que en classe on va dire
c'est différent en tout cas oui ça va
poser problème un minimum sur les acquis
il va falloir il va falloir prendre tout
ça à la rentrée je suppose parce que
l'on s'oriente vers une reprise en
septembre d'après parce que je peux
entendre par ci par là ça va être
compliqué quand même mais le gène moi ce
que je sais ce que je souhaite vraiment
ce que des souris le rouge souhaite
c'est que cette perte à une prise de
conscience sur les yeux l'utilité
sociale des métiers de la santé de
l'éducation et qu'on arrête d'arroser le
privé sans arrêt les entreprises et
qu'on mette de l'argent enfants dont les
choses qui font fonctionner la société
ça qui ça peut être le même pagetti les
libéraux peuvent arrêter d'être
dogmatiques là dessus c'est très
formidable merci bourrelet de nicolas
merci beaucoup nicolas venir d'avoir
répondu à nos questions il rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant et membre du
mouvement citoyen des stylos rouges